bonjour à tous et merci d'être là
donc nous sortons de notre beau week end
où s'est déroulée samedi notre conseil
national une belle journée de travail
avec notamment de nombreuses et échanges
à huis clos
le matin qui a permis qui ont permis à
tous les conseillers nationaux de poser
leurs questions et de s'exprimer car la
droite de retour
c'est aussi de nouvelles pratiques et
c'est très important de remettre les
conseillers nationaux
nos militants au coeur du débat ce
conseil national a aussi été l'occasion
de valider les instances dirigeantes
le bureau politique la commission
nationale d'investitures ainsi que la
commission des recours dans ces
instances toutes les sensibilités sont
représentés elles sont paritaires et
évidemment tous les territoires sont
présents donc nous nous engageons
maintenant c'est un point de départ de
la refondation de la droite dans cette
idée de rassemblement
nous allons pouvoir entamer une période
programmatique avec un travail de fond
sur de nombreux sujets que sont l'europe
l'immigration la sécurité l'économie
l'écologie est donc le prochain conseil
national aura lieu et notamment au mois
de juin ou juillet voilà il sera sur la
thématique de l'europe
je vais passer la parole à gilles sur un
sujet qui est très important
il va vous démontrer merci beaucoup
laurent soit nous souhaitons insister
dans ce début de semaine qui sera pour
un certain nombre de personnels
soignants une semaine de mobilisation et
notamment demain avec le vaste mouvement
national et est relativement inédit dans
son ampleur et dans son attention dans
les établissements de prise en charge
des personnes dépendantes dans les ehpad
nous souhaitons à apporter l'éclairage
et la vision qu'ont les républicains sur
un problème de société qui touche un
nombre très important de familles parce
que si près de sept cent mille français
sont concernés par la prise en charge
dans les ehpad
on imagine bien ce que représente le
nombre de familles impacté dans notre
pays et il y a
pour nous une véritable inquiétude
aujourd'hui sur ce que la grande
dépendance n'est pas assez prise en
charge et même prise en compte par
l'état il nous semble en effet que les
conditions mêmes de l'avancée en âge
l'augmentation de la durée moyenne de
vie qui peut être une formidable chance
pour notre pays lui offre aussi les
conditions d'un redoutable défi s'il
n'est pas assez accompagné par la
puissance publique
ce défi c'est évidemment la façon dont
nous entrevoyons les dernières années de
vie et la dignité que nous souhaitons
voir appliquer dans les établissements
qui recueille aujourd'hui des résidents
de plus en plus dépendants parfois
grabataire et qu'il faut donc
accompagner les chiffres vous les
connaissez c'est un niveau de prise en
charge pour chaque personnel qui a
tendance à s'accroître
ce sont également des moyens notamment
des moyens de l'état via les agences
régionales de santé qui sont
insuffisants et je peux vous le dire
comme élue locale sert porte parole
national des républicains mais nous
sommes confrontés sur le terrain à ces
sujets il ya un vrai enjeu de société et
nous ne souhaiterions pas que ce sujet
qui fera encore une fois l'objet d'une
mobilisation inédite demain soit passée
sous silence
et d'ailleurs nous souhaitons également
étendre cette réflexion parce que
au-delà des personnels des épi
d'un se pose également la question du
personnel des centres hospitaliers
aujourd'hui est une mission a été
présenté qui avait été confié à une
personnalité indépendante en fin d'année
dernière à la suite à la suite du
suicide d'un médecin dans un hôpital
public a très clairement montré dans ses
conclusions en début d'année que les
personnels étaient soumis à des
conditions de travail de plus en plus
redoutables bien évidemment il faut
veiller à la dépense publique et nous
regrettons d'ailleurs que le
gouvernement peut être n'aille pas assez
loin en la matière mais encore faut-il
faire les bons choix
quelle société voulons nous estimons
nous qu' il faut faire des économies sur
le dos de l'hôpital un milliard cinq
dans le projet de loi est la loi de
finances 2010 8
c'est vrai enjeu que nous posons
aujourd'hui en témoignant de solidarité
avec le mouvement qui va se faire jour
demain sont des enjeux qui ne se
règleront pas d'un coup de baguette
magique
il impose forcément si l'on veut que les
personnels soient dans des conditions de
travail qui les rendent eux-mêmes
capable de bien apporter la mission est
de porter correctement la mission qu'ils
ont aux bénéfices et des passions et des
résidents que ces moyens soient mises à
disposition et en tout cas ce ne sont
pas les premiers gestes de la ministre
de la santé qui sont de nature à nous
rassurer en la matière donc c'est la
solidarité totale avec le mouvement
demain et c'est surtout l'engagement des
républicains forts verme auprès des
personnels qui assurent vis-à-vis des
patients vis-à-vis des résidents
notamment sur les derniers temps de leur
vie les conditions d'une prise en charge
dans la dignité de l'avancement en âge
et de la dépendance
on va peut-être maintenant vous laisser
la parole
si vous souhaitez la prendre
merci bonjour une question à vous deux
questions d'actualité concernant le
ministre darmana au delà de la
présomption d'innocence puisque certains
de vos responsables se sont déjà
prononcés là-dessus considérez vous
qu'il puisse encore rester au
gouvernement
merci nous respectons la présomption
d'innocence mais compte tenu des graves
accusations qui sont portées et pour la
sérénité de l'action publique nous
pensons qu'il n'a pas d'autre choix que
de démissionner merci at il une autre
question quel commentaire portez vous
sur les élections législatives
partielles qui ont eu lieu hier et
seconde question pourquoi laurent
wauquiez ne fait pas campagne alors sur
les élections législatives nous notons
les résultats mais vous savez nous
sommes pour les uns et les autres
engagés avons été engagés et seront
engagés demain dans des élections
et croyez bien que on parlera d'eux des
résultats lundi prochain lorsqu'ils
seront définitifs nous sommes
aujourd'hui sur un premier tour on prend
note des évolutions que vous avez
d'ailleurs vous même relevé mais nous
attendons que la campagne se termine
laurent wauquiez et les républicains
sont en appui des candidats qui sont les
nôtres il n'y a pas de sujet là dessus
et croyez bien que notre formation
politique est en soutien total avec ces
candidats qui qui représentent nos
couleurs et qui d'ailleurs voilà sont
dans la philosophie politique qui est la
nôtre on a beaucoup de débat sur la
diversité je note simplement que des
candidats qui représente notre famille
politique aujourd'hui attire jusqu'à eu
un nombre significatif de suffrages sans
savoir s'ils appartiennent à une droite
plutôt qu'à une autre c'est vraiment un
message d'unité que nous avons sur le
terrain comme nous entendons l'avoir sur
nationale donc soyez bien assuré que la
famille des républicains est
intégralement mobilisés avec tous les
militants sur le terrain et à tous les
niveaux
compris dans cette maison au profit de
leur victoire dimanche prochain
y at il d'autres
sion ou avons nous épuiser le sujet si
on va pas mais c'est tout bon pour vous
très bien merci beaucoup et à la semaine
prochaine
merci